- [Instructor] In this
video we're going to talk
about economic growth,
and I wanna be very careful here.
Because depending on the context,
people, including economists,
might mean different things
by economic growth.
In everyday language
when people are talking
about economic growth,
they're usually just
talking about an expansion
in the output of an economy over time.
So if real GDP is increasing,
they might consider that
to be economic growth.
But the context that
we're going to talk about
in this video,
and this is one that you
might see in an introductory
economics class or an AP economics class,
we aren't just talking about an increase
in real GDP over time.
We are talking about an
increase in the full employment
output over time,
regardless of where we are
in the economic cycle.
So keep that in mind as
you watch this video.
If we're just talking about the increase
of real GDP, we're gonna
call that an expansion,
not necessarily economic growth.
And we're gonna call real GDP decreasing
as being equal to a contraction.
When we talk about economic growth,
we're actually talking
about the full employment
output increasing.
And this could happen
somewhat independently
of where we are in the
actual economic cycle.
Let's do a little diagram to
make that a little bit clearer.
So right over here I have plotted real GDP
of an economy versus time.
And what you see here in
yellow is how the real GDP
is fluctuating and it's fluctuating
around its full employment output.
Let's pick this time right
over here, call it t sub one.
So right at this point,
that is our full employment output.
Let's call it y sub f sub one.
But we see that our economy is performing
above our full employment output.
We have a positive output gap.
If we go from that point in time,
fast forward a little bit to t two.
So let's go to sub two here.
Because the y sub f right over here,
the full employment output
right over here is flat,
according to this we
would not have experienced
any economic growth from
t sub one to t sub two,
even though the real GDP would have grown.
We would've grown from
this point to this point
right over here.
So one way to think about it is,
we are expanding as long as
this curve is upward sloping,
but if the full employment
output is not changing,
we are not experiencing economic growth.
The times where we actually are
experiencing economic growth
are times where our full
employment output is changing,
so let's say from this
time right over there
to this time right over there.
And notice, that is
happening, theoretically,
during a contraction.
This is a contraction right over here
where real GDP is actually pulling back.
But if we knew truly what the
full employment output were
and were able to plot it like this,
theoretically we actually are experiencing
economic growth here,
despite a contraction.
To appreciate this,
let's look at other models
that we have studied in economics.
So we think about a production
possibilities curve.
The ones that we typically see
only have two goods or services.
A real economy's gonna
be much more complex.
It would have millions
of goods and services,
but it's very hard to
draw a million-dimension
production possibilities curve.
But what this shows us
is at a snapshot in time,
what is the full employment output.
And it shows us the
trade-off between these two
goods or services.
Now if we're in a situation
where we're behind
the production possibilities curve,
that is a negative output gap,
and it's possible that over time,
we go from this negative output gap
back to the production
possibilities curve.
That would be an expansion in the economy,
but by the definition that
we're talking about here,
which is not what is
typically talked about
in the news or something like this,
we would not call that economic growth.
Economic growth happens when we push out
the production possibilities curve,
when we have an increase in
our full employment output.
So economic growth is maybe through
some new technology or some more workers
or resources or just better institutions,
we're able to push our production
possibilities curve out.
This is an example of economic,
economic growth.
So for example,
this could be our production
possibilities curve
at let's say t three
where this is t sub three right over here,
and then this is our
production possibilities curve
at t sub four,
where this is t sub four right over here,
where our full employment
output has increased.
We can also think about the same idea
using our aggregate demand
or aggregate supply model.
When we studied that,
we saw that in the short-run,
because of say a demand
shock or a supply shock,
we could be operating
to the left or the right
of our full employment output,
creating these positive
or negative output gaps,
but over time we're going to gravitate
back to this full employment output.
And so as long as our
production possibilities curve
isn't getting pushed out, isn't changing,
or as long as our long-run
aggregate supply curve
is not changing,
according to the definition
that I'm talking about
in this video, we are not
seeing economic growth.
The analog for what we
saw in this PPC curve
is maybe this is the long-run
aggregate supply curve
at t three,
but if our economy has more resources,
maybe more population,
more natural resources,
better technology, better institutions,
maybe it's able to produce
more at full employment.
And in that situation,
our long-run aggregate
supply curve would shift
to the right.
And so this could be our long-run
aggregate supply curve at time t four.
So this is full employment
output let's call that sub three.
This would be full
employment output sub four.
The big takeaway here is,
regardless of where we
are in the expansion
or contraction of our business cycles,
the economic growth is the
change in that blue line.
And if we're looking at
the PPC it's a shift out
of our PPC, of our production
possibilities curve.
If we're looking at the aggregate demand
aggregate supply model,
it is a shift to the right of our long-run
aggregate supply curve.
And once again,
what are the things that can cause that?
And these are good to know.
There's a notion of capital.
Traditionally people have just
thought hey more factories,
more resources, more land,
maybe that will push things out,
and it definitely could.
But more modern definitions
are thinking human capital.
Hey if we have a better
educated workforce,
a more skilled workforce,
that could also matter.
People also think about
things like technology.
If we can discover better
ways of putting together
the resources we have,
that can also increase our productivity,
and that's what we would call technology
in an economics context.
And things like
institutions matter as well.
You could imagine if your bureaucracy
is really slows things down,
if it takes forever to get
a permit to do something,
well that might put a hamper on what
the full employment output is.
But if the institutions
become much more efficient,
well then that might allow the country,
allow that economy, to produce
more at full employment.
So all of these things
could push out your PPC,
could push your long-run
aggregate supply curve
to the right, or cause this blue curve
which represents your
full employment output
to move up over time.
All of that would be economic growth.